think counter strike with hero elements
that's the elevator pitch for valor in
Riot Games first competitive fps I say
that not to disparage valor --nt though
in fact that's what I love most about it
especially since it executes on the
formula extremely well valor it thrives
because of tight tactical gameplay and a
mix of character based abilities that
provide a necessary strategic layer
although it's a slim package with
limited features and Baron presentation
valor --nt has the potential to be great
the core motive element revolves around
five on five matches and a best-of 25
rounds demolition style with attackers
and defenders of bomb sites the stakes
are high as everyone gets only one life
per round and the focus on precise
gunplay with low time to kill leaves a
little margin for error
teams account for buying gear and
ability charges based on money allocated
on a per round basis in turn each round
maintains a high level of intensity as
the tide of advantage can shift at any
moment agents introduce an essential
x-factor to the mix with their unique
abilities while it's easy to compare
them to overwatch as heroes valor ins
agent abilities function more like gear
in a loadout most are subject to limited
uses per round or cooldowns and knowing
how and when to execute these abilities
including Ultimates that can come in
clutch is key especially for highly
competitive matches it'd be tough to
break down the abilities of all 11
agents but their purposes are easy to
parse through their four different roles
I personally love Ray's an explosive
offensive agent jet who focuses on
mobility and sage the only healer whose
essential for any team composition each
agent has the capacity to be affected
without feeling like a chore to play
understanding their use case will put
you in a better position to win even
more so when used in conjunction with
teammates but you'll also know how to
react when you see your opponent using
similar tactics it all seems well
balanced at this point
oh yeah now this isn't your typical
shooter every gun has specific recoil
patterns you'll need to understand and
you'll need to get a habit of
effectively peeking around corners and
holding specific sight lines there's a
distinct tempered pace to how it's
played further emphasized by the
importance of sound footsteps gunfire
and abilties going off will tip you on
enemy positions and strategies this is
all to say that valor --nt maintains a
certain calculated design the ushers in
the fundamental aspect you'd expect from
a good tactical shooter valance dynamics
are enough to sustain it as a
competitive shooter worth investing time
into because winning itself is an
intrinsic reward built on the merits of
strong gameplay the time-tested
demolition mode remains an enticing
context for thrilling FPS moments
because of how much it stresses skill
and strategy just like counter-strike or
Rainbow six siege but it cuts both ways
as the experience can sometimes devolve
into frustration it's not necessarily
valor ins fault rather its inherent to
this style of game being stuck with a
poorly coordinated team will make these
long winded matches feel like a drag
it's one area we expect the valent
experience to improve with ranked
matchmaking squatting up with friends
mitigates the problem of course and at
least in my experience random teammates
have been willing to work together and
coordinate more often than not
full matches are a considerable time
investment but there's a bite-size mode
called spike rush
it's a best-of-seven that runs about ten
minutes so you can get your fill without
the long-term commitment the buy phase
is dropped in favor of randomize
loadouts all attackers carry bombs and
agent abilities are charged at the start
of the round power-ups are scattered on
the map to play it up as an arcade-style
mode it'd be nice to have variations on
this mode since spike rush negates some
of the core strategic elements and feels
a bit too short but it offers a welcome
change of pace when you want it
currently valiant features only four
maps to play at random they're designed
with balance and symmetry in mind so
they make for proper competitive
battlegrounds some have key map features
like havens third bomb site and binds
cross map teleporters that accelerate
site rotations but otherwise each map
feels very similar a lot of this
sentiment can be attributed to valence
bland art style
I understand it's meant to be a low spec
game that can run on old hardware and
the visuals make it easy to distinguish
what's happening on screen
prioritizing function over flash but it
doesn't negate the fact that Valerie
isn't particularly exciting to look at
whether spectator or player to its
credit valence character designs bring
in a touch of charisma to the game
although some agents seem similar to
heroes we've seen before it's a somewhat
diverse roster with slick looking agents
but the game loses out on their
potential by mostly relying on generic
personalities or tired character tropes
there also isn't much of a world around
valor in and in the Age of games like
apex legends overwatch and even riots
own League of Legends an element of
fanfare is missing as for progression
you'll earn XP through completing
matches and daily goals then you have
contracts which are essentially
progression tracks to unlock an
assortment of cosmetics you start with 5
agents in the base roster and can unlock
the rest through earning enough XP or
paying for them since I use the
reviewers account several gun skins and
10,000 VP the premium currency were
included to unlock all the agents
however gun skins can be pretty
expensive at least there's no pay to win
or loot box elements here and keep in
mind that Valerie is a free to play game
overall valent has a strong foundation
in its gameplay although it doesn't
break new ground the dynamic of sharp
gunplay and ancient abilities would make
counter-strike and overwatch proud valor
and easily captures the competitive
highs of a good intense match at the
risk of pigeonholing you and a bad one
but outside the standard mode and its
slight variation of Spike Rush and the
four maps it's quite bare-bones
regardless balance in a good state it's
not great but it certainly can be
never had a doubt this is David going